what's going on guys this is rob and if
you're enjoying the content that i'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe
and you can also offer suggestions on
topics and characters and storylines and
whatnot that we can have discussions on
later on in this channel
so what i want to do here is run over
the untold origin
of thor's hammer and i'll be honest with
you guys this was an
amazing story not only that at the end
of this video i'm going to drop a
bombshell on you guys on the reason for
why i think
odin's son is not able to lift the
hammer of thor having said that if you
guys have been following
you know jason aaron's run so far with
regards to uh jane foster thor the
mighty thor
one of the things you guys may have
noticed is that there's a huge learning
curve which is to say that jane foster
isn't completely aware of what she's
capable of and this is natural this is
one of the reasons why i like jason
aaron's run so much because he focuses
on the fact that jane foster
doesn't really know what she's doing she
has a general idea but all she knows is
what she saw
thor do she's never actually been you
know been thor herself and so when she
took over the mantle from odin's son
then it just became this instance where
she was quite literally flying by the
seat of her pants
in addition to this she's always had
this underlying feeling that the hammer
itself was sentient and a lot of this
was because
the hammer would take her to places it
wouldn't necessarily be that she would
go there on her own it would be the
hammer would just take her there
and that's what happens in this
particular story after the events of the
last story arc which really aren't
extremely relevant to the events of this
story
jane foster is suddenly transported to
the farthest reaches of space now this
is one of the cool things about jason
aaron's run
prior to his time on the thor series it
was really just this idea that there was
asgard floating out in a dimension
somewhere there were other realms that
were around it but we didn't really know
how deep all this stuff went what jason
aaron tells us
is that there is or i guess he
established this a god butcher really uh
there is this this sort of library like
this this central place which is kind of
like the nexus where all the gods go to
so the gods of olympus and the gods of
hindu
belief systems the gods of asgard and
you know
basically every single god in existence
knows of this location now
this does not mean cosmic entities
there's a big difference in marvel
comics between cosmic entities
and gods whenever it is that you know
comic book writer is released in this
instance when jason aaron's talking
about gods he's talking about the
earthly and alien pantheons of gods
god's native to those planets or races
the cosmic entities just represent
aspects of the universe itself so i just
wanted to clear that up for those of you
guys who are a little curious who may
have been
wondering this as we were going through
this discussion but because there is
this giant nexus this location you know
jane foster is learning about this for
the very first time what we're also
being told is that there are thousands
of gods this is in stark contrast to the
events of god butcher where by gore had
quite literally been traveling around
the cosmos and killing off gods left and
right and so because
you know a lot of them are starting to
crop back up again it tells us of course
that god seemed to be eternal
but jason aaron doesn't really seem to
bridge this gap but again jane foster is
not the main focus here
the main focus is the hammer when she's
talking to the to the high lore
librarian the person that basically
keeps track of all the records
of everything that has ever happened in
the universe the
the statement she makes here is that for
her this is all new but at the same time
she had also felt that the hammer that
she wields is sentient now this is
something that
the high lord librarian always knew he
always knew this hammer was sent to him
because he knows the full history of it
and he actually gives it to us what he
says
is that there was a point in the history
of asgard's existence
whereby the trolls i'm sorry the yeah
the trolls had waged war against the
dwarves
the issue with this was that while odin
would have normally stepped away and
would have just
allowed this conflict to unfold
naturally as he does in some instances
the dwarves are the best craftsmen when
it comes to
forging raw materials into weapons or
into items that can be used by other
members of the nine realms and so for
odin if
the the dwarves were to be wiped out his
ability to have weapons crafted using
the very rare metals that exist on their
own
in their own realm you know their
ability to craft weapons that would be
formidable in their own right would be
completely and utterly lost simply
because the trolls don't have the
ability to forge those kind of weapons
and so odin had effectively stepped
in and odin had quickly defeated the
trolls and cast them out of the realm of
the
of the dwarves in response the dwarves
thanked odin by presenting him
with a rock with a piece of uber metal
now this i want to have a discussion
about
especially when it comes to uru metal
versus adamantium because i have seen
this discussion
so many times so many people ask this
question
which one's stronger uber metal or
adamantium well like we talked about in
my video on adamantium versus vibranium
or adamantium and vibranium
true adamantium which is what was bonded
to wolverine's skeleton
is completely indestructible once it
hardens or at least is supposed to be
uru metal has the ability to absorb
magic and the magic that it absorbs
makes it stronger having said that
thor's hammer would not be able to break
adamantium but it would be able to put a
dent in it and we've seen that before
we've seen
thor's hammer capable of denting true
adamantium but that's about as far as it
goes but the fact remains that with the
exception of adamantium
thor's hammer this this uh uru metal is
one of the most durable
strongest and you know magic sensitive
metals out there in existence right now
and so with it being presented to odin
this is basically the dwarves presenting
him with the absolute
best gift they can possibly offer the
rarest and strongest material in
existence now what jason aaron does is
he transitions to the other side of the
cosmos and he tells us that there was
this storm lingering on the horizon now
this is really jason aaron being a
little like you know
i guess meta e i don't know that's
really a word that i can use this is
jason aaron uh
not really being specific but just to
say this isn't really like the storm
representing an individual the storm's
not a being the storm is simply just a
storm but he gives it personality and
what he says is that this storm had been
lingering on the horizon and it had been
making its way across the cosmos wiping
out planets destroying galaxies you know
and eventually
it set its sight so i guess it made its
way over to asgard and so by providing
this storm with personality jason aaron
is basically telling us
that this storm is intended to
completely obliterate asgard now because
odin has the odin force which is the
life force of his two brothers vilian v
which he's combined into himself to make
him durable odin is extremely
powerful in his own right and because of
this odin used the combined force of the
of the odin force itself
against this storm while he was able to
hold it at bay his energies were able to
send the storm into a fray send it into
a swirl and odin took the
took the uru medal that he was given by
the dwarves and can find the storm
inside of it and so with this storm
confined odin's idea was that if this
storm is so powerful
that is capable of wiping out entire
solar systems and galaxies and so on
then this this storm can basically be
forged or this rock can be forged
into a weapon that odin can use and so
what he did
is he went to the dwarves and he said
craft me a weapon out of this chunk of
uru metal with a storm inside
so that i could have a weapon that none
can challenge a weapon that no one can
stand against
and so what happened is that because
uber metal was almost impossible to mold
because it was almost impossible to
craft it presented one heck of a
challenge for the dwarves but over the
course of 17 days
combining the efforts of thousands of
dwarves all working together
they were eventually able to mold this
chunk of uru metal into a hammer and the
hammer itself was presented to thor
as the pinnacle of any weapon that would
ever exist within the nine realms
the issue with this was that the storm
inside the hammer was still
raging it was still wildly powerful and
it seemed to have a mind of its own and
so the result of this is that when odin
went to go pick up the hammer he was
unable to wield it effectively because
the hammer was wild it basically took
odin where it wanted to go and odin
couldn't keep it confined
and so what odin did is he came along
and he put an enchantment on the hammer
that said anybody who picks it up or
anybody who tries to pick it up will not
be able to lift it now
jason aaron doesn't tell us what this
enchantment is
he does not tell us if it's the
enchantment that he made where he said
you know those who are worthy
will possess the power of thor or if it
was a different enchantment i would go
as far as to say especially with what we
see here with uh with his younger you
know with the
his firstborn thor being curious about
the hammer knowing thor would go on to
lift it it was basically a precursor
to that particular enchantment so that
odin was able to come back later on and
modify it and saying
that anyone you know those who prove
themselves worthy will be able to
possess the hammer of thor but again
we're not giving any given any specifics
here all we really know
is that odin put an enchantment on this
hammer so that nobody could wield it but
it seemed as though because the hammer
was sentient because of the fact that
the storm
inside could decide who was able to
wield it and who was not able to wield
it that the hammer decided
thor would be able to wield it so that
when thor you know came of age he was
able to pick up the hammer and carry it
around and use it as a superhero having
said that
because of the fact that the hammer in
and of itself seems to be sentient based
on what it is that we're told
while the events of this comic basically
conclude going forward into the upcoming
story as part of marvel now
called the war of realms presumably
leading into thor the unworthy
and the return of odin's son the big
huge bomb that i want to drop here is
with regards to what it was that nick
fury said to thor now
as we know in original sin the original
sin event that marvel did as part of
their lead-up to jonathan hickman's
avengers and new avengers and the
i guess the events of secret wars the
incursions and so on during a conflict
with nick fury it was always assumed
that nick fury had said something to
thor
that made it impossible for him to lift
the hammer it made him unworthy
i would make the argument that it's not
because nick fury said something to thor
that kept him from lifting the hammer i
think nick fury said something to the
hammer
that made it so that thor couldn't pick
it up that's my
take on this that nick fury spoke to the
hammer and the hammer decided thor
wasn't worthy of wielding it anymore now
what it was that nick fury said to that
hammer that the principle still stays
the same
what wasn't nick fury said we don't know
and jason aaron may never tell us
i have no real idea here but it seems as
though he's moving in that direction
that he is going to tell us what it is
that you know nick fury said that kept
odin's son from being able to wield the
hammer most likely it'll be covered in
thor the unworthy at least i would hope
so if it is you'll definitely hear from
me
if it's not well then i don't know i
mean i'm sure i'll do a video on four of
the unworthy when that storyline
completes but it'll be six months before
that happens but or at least assuming it
comes out as a monthly series it'll be
six months but if you guys are new here
to the
two comics explained make sure you guys
uh drop a like make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core
and yeah leave a comment down below let
me know what you guys think about jason
aaron modifying the history of thor's
hammer to make it sentient to make it
something that can actually
think for itself as opposed to just
being wielded you know being an object
that's lifted by whoever's worthy of
picking it up but that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end and
i will catch you guys later
peace
[Music]
you